IS "THE FIVE" ."
YOU ARE LOOKING LIVE AT
CAPITOL HILL WHERE WE ARE
AWAITING A SENATE FOREIGN
RELATIONS COMMITTEE VOTE ON THE
NOMINATION OF MIKE POMPEO FOR
SECRETARY OF STATE.
NO DEMOCRAT ON THE PANEL
SUPPORTS HIS NOMINATION.
NEITHER DOES REPUBLICAN
RAND PAUL, MEANING POMPEO WON'T
HAVE ENOUGH SUPPORT FOR A
FAVORABLE RECOMMENDATION.
BUT MAJORITY LEADER
MITCH MCCONNELL STILL INTENDS TO
HOLD A FULL CONFIRMATION VOTE
THIS WEEK ON THE FLOOR.
THREE SENATE DEMOCRATS SO FAR IS
THAT THEY WILL BACK HIM.
JOE MANCHIN, DONNELLY, HEIDI
HEITKAMP.
THEY WENT HAS PRAISED THEM BUT
BLASTS THE POINT LESS
OBSTRUCTION OF THE REST OF THE
PARTY.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO DIRECTOR
POMPEO, IT'S ABSOLUTELY
OUTRAGEOUS THAT HE WOULD NOT
MOVE THROUGH QUICKLY.
HE IS EXTREMELY QUALIFIED FOR
THE POSITION.
NOT ONLY THE WHITE HOUSE BUT ALL
OF AMERICA SHOULD BE CALLING ON
THE SENATE TO ACTUALLY DO THEIR
JOB, DO WHAT THEY ARE REQUIRED
AND EXPECTED TO DO.
THAT IS TO HELP GOVERNMENT
FUNCTION AND HELP ON THE SAFETY
AND SECURITY OF OUR COUNTRY.
I THINK FRANKLY FOR PARTICULAR
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS THAT IT'S
VERY HARD FOR THEM TO JUSTIFY
VOTING IN FAVOR OF SOMEONE LIKE
JOHN KERRY AND NOT FOLLOWING
SUIT AND VOTING IN FAVOR OF MIKE
POMPEO.
>> Jesse: THE PRESIDENT ADDING
ADDING:
"HARD TO BELIEVE OBSTRUCTIONISTS
MAY VOTE AGAINST MIKE POMPEO
FOR SECRETARY OF STATE.
THE DEMS WILL NOT APPROVE
HUNDREDS OF GOOD PEOPLE,
NEED MORE REPUBLICANS!"
KIMBERLY, WEST POINT GUY,
HARVARD GUY, INCREDIBLE
CREDENTIALS.
SARAH SANDERS MADE A GREAT
POINT.
JOHN KERRY WAS CONFIRMED, SAME
THING WITH HILLARY.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> Kimberly: AN EXTRAORDINARY
INDIVIDUAL WITH AN INCREDIBLE
BACKGROUND, HISTORY,
QUALIFICATIONS, DEDICATION OF
THE COUNTRY.
STEADFASTLY PROVED HIMSELF TO BE
MORE THAN WORTHY OF THE
POSITION.
WE ARE LUCKY TO HAVE HIM.
YOU HAVE THE DEMOCRATS
COMPLETELY WITH THE WOOL PULLED
OVER THEIR EYES BECAUSE THEY
ONLY SEE OBSTRUCTION.
THEY JUST WANT TO BE ABLE TO
STEP IN THE WAY OF A FINE
AMERICAN THAT SHOULD BE SERVING
THE COUNTRY AND CONTINUING IN
THIS CAPACITY.
SADLY, OUT OF PURE POLITICS,
THERE IS NO OTHER GOOD ANSWER,
MOTIVATION.
THEY ARE OBJECTING TO HIM.
WHY?
TO TRY TO PREVENT
PRESIDENT TRUMP FROM PUTTING
THROUGH HIS AGENDA.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS MADE
TREMENDOUS INROADS IN FOREIGN
POLICY AND NATIONAL SECURITY,
SHOWING STRENGTH AND RESOLVE IN
SYRIA.
SHOWING STRENGTH AND RESOLVE
WITH IRAN AND NORTH KOREA,
MAKING MANIFEST CHANGE.
SOMETHING NO OTHER
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN ABLE TO
DO THE QUITE BE ABLE TO FIGURE
OUT THE SITUATION.
THIS COURSE CORRECTION IN
NATIONAL SECURITY HISTORY.
NEVERTHELESS, THIS IS SOMEONE HE
NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO DO NEW WITH
THE MISSION TO BE ABLE TO DO
THIS AND SERVE THE CIA AND NOW
CAN DO THIS IN THE
STATE DEPARTMENT WHICH IS
SORELY IN NEED OF SOME
STRUCTURE, DISCIPLINE, FOCUS FOR
ALL OF THE HARDWORKING PEOPLE TO
GET SMARTER AND PUT IT IN PLACE.
WHAT ARE WE DOING?
WE ARE DELAYING IT.
WHO WAS IT HURTING?
THE COUNTRY AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: IT IS.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
REASONING, AS KIMBERLY SAID, HAS
TO DO WITH POLITICS.
WE RESEARCHED IT.
DIANNE FEINSTEIN SAID I SENSE A
CERTAIN DISDAIN FOR DIPLOMACY.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT MEANS.
HOW IS SHE SENSING THAT?
>> Greg: COMPARING JOHN KERRY
TO MIKE POMPEO IS LIKE COMPARING
A STICK OF DRIFTWOOD TO AN
IPHONE.
ONE IS IRRELEVANT AND THE OTHER
THING YOU CAN DO SO MANY THINGS
WITH.
IT'S A CLASH BETWEEN ADULTS AND
CHILDREN.
THE CHILDREN BURDENED THE WORLD
WITH INFANTILE TRIBALISM.
IT'S A TEAM SPORT.
WITH POMPEO'S INVOLVEMENT IN
NORTH KOREA WHICH IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT, THE DEMOCRATS TRYING
TO BLOCK IT AND RAND PAUL TRYING
TO BLOCK IT, IT'S LIKE DURING
THE OLYMPICS, TRYING TO TAKE OUT
YOUR STAR TEAMMATE WHO IS IN THE
MIDDLE OF SOMETHING.
THEY ARE TRYING TO PULL A TONYA
HARDING ON NANCY KERRIGAN.
THEY ARE THE VERGE OF SOMETHING
BIG WHICH IS DENUKING
NORTH KOREA.
>> Kimberly: MY KNEE HURTS
JUST FROM TALKING ABOUT IT.
>> Jesse: WHY ARE YOU TRYING
TO PULL A NANCY KERRIGAN, JUAN?
THE OPPOSITION TO MIKE POMPEO.
>> Juan: YOU CAN START WITH
RAND PAUL.
START WITH THE REPUBLICAN.
IT'S THE REASON YOU WON'T GET
PAST THE COMMITTEE.
>> Jesse: HE DIDN'T VOTE FOR
HIM FOR CIA.
>> Juan: I AM SAYING HE IS A
REPUBLICAN WHO WAS VERY CLEAR
WHO HAS PRINCIPLED OPPOSITION TO
MIKE POMPEO BECAUSE HE FEELS
THAT POMPEO IS INDIFFERENT TO
PRIVACY CONCERNS AND HAS
DEMONSTRATED THIS IN THE PAST.
HE'S MORE CONCERNED WITH
SECURITY AND GOING ADD IT IN A
FLAT WAY THAT MIGHT ALLOW
AMERICANS 'PRIVACY AND LIBERTY
TO BE INFRINGED UPON.
YOU CAN UNDERSTAND THAT.
>> Jesse: I CAN COME UP FROM
HIS PERSPECTIVE.
>> Juan: FOR THE DEMOCRATS,
YOU MAY HAVE SEEN,
SENATOR BOOKER OF NEW JERSEY WHO
ASKED HIM ABOUT HIS POSITION ON
GAYS AND POMPEO WAS LIKE, I
DON'T APPROVE OF GAY SEXUAL
BEHAVIOR.
YOU HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO SAY
THAT.
THE QUESTION IS WILL IT BECOME
PART OF AMERICAN FOREIGN POLICY
DEALING WITH COUNTRIES WHERE
GAYS ARE KILLED OR PERSECUTED.
>> Greg: THE LEFT DIDN'T SEEM
TO MIND THAT BEFORE.
>> Jesse: WE ARE HEARING THAT
THE SENATOR FROM KENTUCKY,
RAND PAUL, IS A "YES."
>> Juan: IT CHANGES THE
EQUATION.
>> Greg: HE IS WATCHING
"THE FIVE" ."
>> Juan: IF IT IS 11-10 AND
YOU GET THE REPUBLICANS BACK,
YOU WILL GET THE SUPPORT COMING
OUT OF THE COMMITTEE.
DONALD TRUMP PREDICTED THIS, HE
SAID HE THOUGHT RAND PAUL WOULD
COME ON BOARD.
THE IRAN DEAL WHICH IS COMING UP
SHORTLY IN MAY.
YOU HAVE POMPEO, A LONG-TIME
HARSH CRITIC OF THE DEAL AND
ALSO IN TERMS OF DEALING WITH
NORTH KOREA, HE HAS BEEN A
REALLY HAWKISH PERSON.
IN COMBINATION WITH JOHN BOLTON
WHO HAS NO OBJECTION TO A FIRST
TRY, I THINK IT PUTS A LOT OF
PEOPLE, AND ATTITUDE AS YOU
DESCRIBED IT, THIS GUY IS NOT
ABOUT DIPLOMACY.
HE IS ABOUT RUNNING PEOPLE OVER.
>> Jesse: BEING A DOVE HAS GOT
US WHERE WE ARE NOW WHERE THEY
ARE ON THE VERGE OF A NUCLEAR
WEAPON CAPABLE OF HITTING THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Katie: MIKE POMPEO HAS DONE
THE JOB OF SECRETARY OF STATE BY
GOING OVER AND MEETING WITH
KIM JONG UN, RIGHT?
HE'S BEEN IN THE POSITION, NOT
OFFICIALLY, BUT HE HAS DONE
DIPLOMACY AT THIGHS LEVEL
POSSIBLE WHEN EVERYONE IS
CRITICIZING HIM, SAYING IT
SHOULD BE DONE AT LOWER LEVELS.
MIKE POMPEO IS A GUY WHO CAN GET
THE JOB DONE, ESSENTIALLY NO
MATTER WHAT IT IS.
HE'S DONE THAT THROUGHOUT HIS
HISTORY.
WHATEVER POSITION HE'S IN, HE'S
BEEN SUCCESSFUL AT ALL OF THOSE
PROFESSIONAL RESPONSIBILITIES.
HE KNOWS WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR HUMAN LIFE, WHAT
IS AT STAKE FOR THE COUNTRY.
IT'S AN ISSUE THAT'S BEEN
SEVERELY POLITICIZED FOR THE
SAKE OF BEING AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
DEMOCRATS WANT IT BOTH WAYS.
THEY'VE BEEN CRITICIZING THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION FOR
DESTROYING THE STATE DEPARTMENT
NOT HAVING DIPLOMATS BY HAVING A